hot breath chase bonnie speaking of on
the
topic of your jokes what's your favorite
joke you've written
new or old hmm
that's a tuffy i guess like
favorite joke i've written
to come to mind i suppose
i don't know um
yeah i mean like i think i think newest
jokes spark the most joy for comics
especially when they think of it try it
and it works
like that's obviously to me the greatest
joy i guess of up there
with making people laugh is a new joke
working or a new idea being like yes
um which is tough during these times
because we don't really have an audience
to test that out so it's been what two
months now since i filmed my special
which was the last time i performed
stand-up comedy wow
and uh
so i guess i don't want to ruin the joke
but it's a special it's a joke for my
upcoming special about
abortion and the stigma of it being on
women
when it's a two-person connection
i'll um i'll i'll tell you uh
your my favorite joke of yours or uh i
mean
i'm a fan i love your writing but uh
this one was one that just stuck out to
me from your
i first saw it on your conan set in 2017
where it was
oh i hate doing someone's joke but i
think
these are pretty much the words it's i
don't even weigh myself anymore i just
ask someone to draw me and if they reach
for a marker i know that i know i've
gone too far
[Laughter]
that just it's visual and it's it's
concise
and that's something um we had jesse
david fox on here and he talked about
his favorite jokes were
are the ones that like get a lot out in
a short amount of words like you can
see it in a short amount of words and
that's one to me that just like it just
hits and it's quick
and it's just so clever like was that
one that kind of came to mind or did you
really have to like
whittle that one together over months
and months
that one was probably just a come to
mind thing that i was touring with micro
bigly at the time
he was touring the new one and working
on that and shaping it and sharpening it
and um
[Music]
i did it he and i riffed together well
like in the car and stuff and so i i
said what do you think of this and he's
like that's
so funny and then he pitched the if they
reach for a marker
or no wait wait i can't remember if he
pitched that i reached for a marker
or i think i said that and then he said
if they draw a stick figure i agree i
think that's what
his what his tag was i could give him
credit where credit is due
but yeah i forget what it was he we
ripped that out together but
he's also the one he's giving me
confidence on jokes where i'm kind of
like is this anything and he's like yeah
that's so funny
so it's awesome yeah he's definitely
with everything he's doing online he's
definitely a
guest goal or a goal guest to get on
here and answer comic questions
he's a good dude